welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Sonic the Hedgehog released a
new trailer designed to reintroduce the
Sega speedster with a square one
redesigned look after it's kind of
freakish character design from its first
trailer or as the studio calls it well
that first trailer I'm gonna break down
these visuals not just to compare the
before and after but to explain how and
why the CGI in this trailer looks better
to us despite and here's the deeper
truth this new sonic looks way less
natural and falls into some common
animation tropes but that's kind of what
we want so here we go the new less
nightmare-inducing sonic explained and
thank you to privacy comm for sponsoring
this episode if you sign up now at
privacy comm slash new rock stars you
can get $5 today to use on any purchase
online for free so let us start with the
previous trailer in the precise reasons
people reacted so negatively to it some
of the reasons were artificial just
people dogpiling onto something cuz it's
fun and freaking out over every little
thing about him but really the shading
and texturing on old Sonic weren't all
that bad actually pretty similar to what
the artist achieved would detect it
Pikachu
both teams succeeded in transforming a
beloved smooth surface 2d game character
and do something closer to like the 3d
plush doll the problem is while
detective Pikachu is a plush doll you
want a hug forever old Sonic is kind of
like a weird knockoff plush doll that
you find in another country and it makes
your nephew cry when you give it to him
Sanok who is Sanok all you love Sanok he
turns to the turtle and gives you wishes
that's not Sonic also did you follow me
home yeah I am a ghost
the new redesigned Sonic from the latest
trailer fixes that problem by
reconnecting a character to how we
visualize him from these sega games his
anatomy is less humanistic which is okay
because for many of us the sonic we know
lives in a 16-bit world with limited
detail when we think of that Sonic all
we think of is a big blue spiky head
slicked back to make him look like a
ball shape for winning roles we think
big eyes impatient expression black
button nose huge red shoes huge white
gloves not teeth the new sonic makes all
those changes his eyes way bigger his
brow heavier to give him more pronounced
expressions his shoes grew from tiny
tracks printer ones too big impact
to go bright red ones even later in the
trailer when he wears other shoes the
hotel bath slippers they're still pretty
large and cartoony he wears gloves now
because as we've seen with Disney
characters when you try to Amanda made a
character with white gloves you can
never show us their bare fingers his
hair spikes are similar but notice
there's less texture than before it's as
if the artists applied another round of
hair gel to make it even more slicked
back now narrative Lee the previous
trailer tried to go the detective
Pikachu route it began by establishing
Sonic as a kind of fish out of water in
our world he leaves behind a single
thick hair as a clue comes back again
and again pretty unsettling because we
don't think of Sonic as something that
sheds but this new trailer goes a new
route establishing Sonic in his vibrant
videogame world that we're familiar with
been Schwartz's voice narrates to us
reintroducing himself using that whole
reintroduction approach that Spiderman
into the spider verse used to re-explain
that movies complex take on a familiar
property and so it works so well by
embracing Sonic as the animated figure
he has always been now the downside is
the new result is far less lifelike as a
character but that's actually okay
because Sonic is not a life like
Hedgehog that old version fell within
what artists refer to as the uncanny
valley and which the more lifelike you
try to make an animated character the
more you risk slipping into that zone
where the human brain struggles to
recognize it as a human it's just like
uncannily off kill it this has been a
criticism against some of the works of
director Robert Zemeckis like in the
Polar Express and welcome to Marwin in
which he made his animated characters so
lifelike they look like they have no
souls and they don't those characters
are evil meanwhile characters like
Gollum and Wally went through several
redesigns until final versions of them
that had huge expressive eyes that
served as windows into their beautiful
damaged souls and the reason for this is
we have grown up with all animated media
looking a certain way so that our brains
have adjusted to accept huge eyed
cartoonish characters as the ones we
connect with it's our default similarly
our brains have tuned into seeing 24
frames per second as a natural frame
rate of all films even though 60 frames
per second is more vivid and closer to
how our eye functions when we see that
our brain signal to us at something is
slightly off so all this applies to the
most crucial element of the new sonic
design his eyes they are huge they went
from taking a more natural 10% of the
surface area of his face to like a
whopping 40% this trailer makes Sonic's
eyes look even bigger in several moments
by covering the negative space on his
forehead with headbands hats batting
helmets kitchen rags shower towels it's
also worth noting they changed Sonic's
eye color before his eyes were this
unnatural turquoise color which should
be fine
Sonic's fur is also an unnatural blue
color but the eyes are so critical that
the fact that the green reflecting from
his irises it's not the green of the
surrounding exterior triggered a
disconnect in our brain for new sonic
they changed the shade a little bit so
that the green is closer to the green
reflected by the light on the bushes
grass and trees outside in the natural
world real green realize real Sol now
there's one more component to new sonic
size that we have to acknowledge but
before we continue thank you to privacy
comm for sponsoring this episode
privacy calm is a breeze service that
lets you buy things online using virtual
cars instead of your real credit-card
information so that you can protect
yourself on the Internet it's
essentially a digital burner card with
limits say you control privacy comelet's
to avoid having that hand over the keys
to your finances every time you sign up
for a subscription and like forget to
cancel it which I'm convinced is the
main way most of these content providers
make money folks you're just waiting for
you to forget they sign up for that free
trial and then cha-ching so for example
I have set up an account with privacy
linked by bank account and then I
created this card specifically for my
monthly Netflix subscription payments
for this virtual card I'm setting the
limit just above my monthly subscription
amount so if someone tries to use this
privacy card number again where ever
charged it privacy will notify you that
they blocked it because the spending
limit has already been reached it's
simple it's fast it's really just one
click they also are starting to offer
new plans there's the free one that lets
you create up to 12 cards a month but
also there's a new pro plan where you
can get 36 cards a month and 1% cash
back on your purchases there's also a
team's plan that's useful for small
businesses so just head to privacy comm
slash new rockstars and sign up for an
account as a special treat for you guys
new customers will automatically get
five dollars to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only gift
that's free money so just go to privacy
comm slash new rockstars and sign up now
get back to new Sonics eyes almost as
important as the eyes themselves are the
other things that the artist engorged to
reduce the negative space of his
forehead two powerful eyebrows this new
sonic is so damn expressive and that's
largely because these eyebrows are
freakin workhorses now remember in the
games
sonic often furrows his brow he has a
kind of resting face he taps his
foot do you don't move
these new eyebrows reflect that
impatience really well and that brings
us to new Sonic's overall face and
expressions most importantly this new
design reduces the teeth that were so
unsettling in the previous trailer
mouths are notoriously the most
difficult thing for VFX artists to
animate because there are hundreds of
surfaces all over your lips your skin
your teeth your gums we thing that the
uncanny valley is just waiting to drag
you into so if the character is a
cartoon just laying into it shrink that
mouth size or better yet design a mouth
less character now this new Sonic's
teeth rarely catch the light when he
talks in fact if the mouth ever does
catch the eye it's often bent in this
smirk now this is actually 100% an
unnatural human expression this is often
referred to as the DreamWorks face one
eyebrow cocked one eyebrow down mouth
half smile slightly open like try making
this face yourself no one makes this
race yes oh but for so many animated
films and trailers and posters you see
it it's everywhere and not just
DreamWorks films Pixar Disney Animation
illumination and now Sonic like huge
eyes and 24 frames per second we see
that face on animated characters and we
think to ourselves huh this guy's here
for a good time but it's also a bit
naughty probably about to say something
real clever
it's a trope but you know what it works
and in the case of Sonic as much as we
the viewers claim to be ahead of the
curve and our character design tastes
our perceptions of what seems real are
actually locked into how our brains were
programmed when we were children
watching the Latin which might be why we
respond like children when characters
animated the wrong way freak us out what
do you think of this new sonic comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on instagram twitter at da vas and
follow new rock stars on social media
and subscribe to new rock stars here on
YouTube for all of your nightmares to be
explained thank you for watching bye
[Music]